[Applause]
you know him from the rising
you know him from his podcast i got to
get his podcast name right i don't want
to [ __ ] up the podcast name
but you know from the rising and you
know him from the realignment podcast
this is sagar
and jetty i'm telling you this is you
can watch all this stuff on youtube he
went the youtube model
um with his host crystal and they are
literally the only news source i trust
and he's an absolutely [ __ ] great
dude and he's bringing truth
to power and hopefully he answers the
zoom call right now
are we on i see his cute ass okay there
it is looking like a young republican
what's up
no he looks like clark kent um so we
have sagar
and jetty here man you know sagar first
of all i love what you guys do go check
out sauger's show the rising
you can check it out daily um and uh you
guys do it up what
what is it exactly you do a full-length
show and chop it up into clips
yeah basically we do like a two-hour
show and it gets chopped into clips
okay great i absolutely love it it's my
source of news uh
and just to break down what it is you
are you skew conservative
and crystal skus liberal but you don't
hate each other
you call out your own politics you call
out the other side
and you have a very fruitful
conversation about
you know what is happening in the world
today right without like name calling
etc
is that fair to say yeah that's what we
try to do and i think i mean
if there's a core innovation like to
what we do so we're willing to call out
our own side
i mean we're about to talk about the
trump tax story you're not going to go
on fox and you're going to hear anybody
who's on the right
tell you the truth about what just
what's in this story okay so important
break it down for us what is what is
happening what's going on with the trump
story like what was your initial
reaction we were texting a little bit
earlier
um is he not paying okay is he doing
anything illegal that's number one
as far as we know no okay
is he doing anything that we should look
down upon oh yeah 100 but
this is my this is my thing right which
is yeah we should look down
upon it but if you want to look down
upon trump and what he's done here which
i 100 do
then you want to look down on every
billionaire in america i don't think
most people want to have that
conversation hold on hold on
are we looking down upon him for
avoiding taxes yeah
yes he's okay he's he well actually in a
way he's only doing what
you know people like him wrote the laws
to do exactly but that's also
heroic like if i don't know if you're
familiar with our podcast here but the
people on this podcast
we all support people who find ways to
pay less taxes
100 100 akash archives can you speak on
that
i mean yeah sagar you get it you're
indian we will never pay
anything we're supposed to pay ever
everything is a haggle and my dick gets
kind of hard thinking about cheating
taxes
so quite frankly quite frankly
so so akash supports it i support the
idea of
it's not necessarily cheating the taxes
because he's not doing anything illegal
he's taking advantage of these loopholes
that people like him created in the tax
code
right so is it a little bit hypocritical
that there are these
politicians calling him out which at the
same time have been lobbied to create
these very loopholes within the tax code
that's exactly it man which is that look
i don't want to hear it from nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer
yes he literally said so schumer pelosi
and joe biden
all said that one of the first things
you're going to do is
bring back the salt tax deduction which
you new yorkers are probably pissed off
about
the state and local tax deduction which
only benefits people who
are millionaires in new york city and in
san francisco what is what is the
assault effect
what is the assault tax deduction what
is that it's called state and local
taxes so it used to be that you guys
because you have crazy taxes up their
new york city yeah could deduct
the amount that you guys pay in your
state and local taxes from your federal
tax income burden
that was repealed by trump in the time
in the trump tax bill one of the few
good things
actually in that tax bill this does not
sound good to me at all i think that
i think we're on the opposite side of
taxation within this conversation right
now it's for you
it's bad for society it's good my man
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean we didn't come to
america to care about society sauger
right
everybody left their families to come
here for selfish reasons
so they could take care of their self
hoard the wealth baby
yeah also salt tax sagar is how india
got his independence that's why we said
this the last [ __ ] straw
you're not gonna take our spices and
salts from us
that's what we marching for gandhi
marched like 50 miles over this [ __ ] how
dare you sandals bro
dare you support this come on my gran my
great grandmother
was in that salt to march just like you
need to come join us y'all are
[ __ ] sold 100 support women was she
really in that
soul mate yeah she was in you know for a
fact that she was there or you fake news
it's like a proud it's a proud history
legacy man yeah but i'm sure everybody
was like you know i was there like i'm
sure lots of blind
maybe my grandfather lied to me i don't
know say it again she died before i got
to talk look
my grandfather said that he was at the
game where babe ruth
pointed and hit the home run and my
and my dad was like no you weren't a
[ __ ] loser
but that's what people back in the day
did before cameras
you just said you were there like
imagine living in
selma and being black and like not being
at that march of course you're gonna
tell people no i was in the back like
you're gonna say that right yeah you
have to say it you have to maybe you're
right i don't know
we should look into your great grandma
dude yeah be happy i'll send you an
ancestry.com thing whatever
i don't know i bet she was yeah we were
taking long ass walks after heavy meals
so probably she just cooked up some
heavy ass like rookies and mad butter in
the chicken and they were like we just
gotta take a walk
what chicken [ __ ] are you talking
about this is a hundred percent butter
chicken yo
oh he said he's 100 pure vegetarian he's
calling you out of your meat smoking yo
my cat is allowed to eat meat so
i'm looking down on you again oh man you
just outcasted yourself
listen this is a brandman family so i
don't really care oh
wait a minute hey let me tell you
something
let me tell you let me tell you
something a real brahmin would know how
to say brahman
should i should i bring my little string
out all right i should be wearing it you
don't even know the name republican ass
i'm sold out
so now i've got the hair and everything
boy they got you sagar
they got you no he's trying to tax us
all yeah yeah
i'm not into it i am no listen what do
you mean how i thought you're supposed
to be conservative republicans are both
supposed to be anti-tax no big gov
yeah dude this is what my whole show is
about [ __ ] that like that's i don't
agree with that
so what's conservative about you i
should have never brought you on this
[ __ ] man
i like this guy oh my goodness majority
of republican voters actually support a
wealth tax the whole reason trump won is
because he ran against all these other
goobers who are spouting this
anti-tax [ __ ] they're like oh we
need lower taxes
oh that's all we need deficits all sorts
of vast majority of americans
want to see rich people pay more taxes
and they want better public services
that's
it they're just kind of making sen he's
kind of
but the vast majority of americans ain't
rich
pay taxes no that's a good point let me
ask you this soccer actual question not
trying to pick a bone or whatever a joke
around
what makes you conservative if you're in
favor of higher taxes
what am i missing personally what makes
you
that's to presume look oh what's
personally conservative about me i think
like
family is good i think we should have
more family i think people should have
more
kids i think people should have more
flexibility i mean i think religious
people should be able to be religious
like and i know that sounds most people
on the left are like i don't disagree
with any of that but like yeah you know
on an elite level
in terms of policy like some of the
things that people do do
you know disagree with those things so
that's what makes me conservative
so you want to take my money so you can
have a big family is what you're trying
to say yeah basically yes i
see i see i see where we're at okay some
prominent [ __ ]
oh come on sauger come back that's my
politics man
come on okay so what i did read about
when i was reading this thing up about
trump right was that uh
the big story here might not really be
the lack of
taxes paid it might be the debt that he
has
so apparently he has like up to like 400
million dollars in
various debts right and people are going
well if there's a president
of a country that's in debt to certain
financial institutions
how can we be so sure that he isn't
going to do things that benefit
those financial institutions to possibly
alleviate that debt
or you know maybe they uh don't bump
interest rates or just to have good
favor
so how so is there any validity to that
i think it's a fair point i like this is
what i want i want to be clear here look
like
the president united states owing 400
million dollars to anybody is like
is bad if the president like not paying
his taxes and you know acting like every
other billionaire i think that's bad
is that a real sort interrupt is that a
real 400 million or is that a i don't
want to pay taxes 400 million
so it is a real 400 million from what i
can tell so like i said this is clear
which is a lot of people are using
andrew's point and they're like oh my
god it could be owned by russia
it could be owned by you know the
desperate no man like look it's public
record
it's literally out there in the
financial disclosure i actually sent it
to andrew
if you guys can throw it up on the
screen i don't know i'll say it's audio
whatever yeah um but like this actually
look at it look it's mostly deutsche
bank
um and some other real estate financial
holding companies
and you can go through and you can look
those are majority u.s controlled people
but again i don't want to excuse this
stuff like i don't think it is a good
thing
that the president owes all this money
to people do i think he could be like
blackmailed by a foreign entity because
of it no
you know that's [ __ ] and so i just
think we need to be very like
clear here about what exactly is
happening right and do you think it's
possible that
they would call in those loans because
that's what the uh
you know catastrophists are doing right
now they're going what if these what if
these debtors calling their loans how is
he going to pay it off
well doesn't he not to defend trump but
like doesn't he have
assets i imagine a couple of those
buildings that his name's on he probably
owns right
yes dude if he he owns a boeing 757 like
he owns
real estate all over the world that's a
dope way to pay off your debt
if they called in the loans like i think
he'll be fined like he
probably could pay 400 million it might
leave him strapped with cash but right
yes
he owns more than 400 million dollars in
assets so the real story here which
everybody's missing is
rich people get to skip out on taxes
yeah and we're hyper focused on trump
because obviously he's a lightning rod
but maybe we should be focused on the
tax code and trying to find ways to make
it more
i guess fair for the average person yeah
i mean i mean
check this out so the federal reserve
actually came out with a chart today you
see how we're bringing a hood out of
sauger he said check
he said yo check this let's go you can't
talk like down the horizon loosen up
that tie
baby i see you hit one of these
bro okay go let me check it check it
what are we gonna start
federal reserve came out today bottom 50
of americans own almost no wealth and
the the rest of the data shows
79 of wealth in the united states is
owned by
either millionaires or billionaires so
that's 80 80
of wealth by millionaires and
billionaires that's only 11
of the country 11 okay so let's think
about that i mean does it make sense for
of the wealth to be concentrated in the
top 11 percent of the country
and who are the people that the
politicians listen to i mean this is
what we talk about on our show which is
that
like we said these are the people who
write the laws there are intent there
are whole
buildings here in dc who are built to
lobby
specifically for what trump gets away
with by not paying taxes
which is real estate deductions these
are some of the most powerful people
in washington because and i was trying
to i was kind of explaining this to you
because it's kind of
it can seem complicated it's actually
simple which is
real estate developer buys a piece of
property for 100 million
then he doesn't want to pay taxes so he
gets somebody to assess the building for
90 million
and then can write off 10 million
dollars in deductions
for years and years and years in the
future even though he never lost any
real
income so or yeah let's say if the
building gets more expensive
because he upgraded it you can write off
your investment cost
either way you don't pay any money yeah
so so
this is the best thing to understand
here yeah so just to clarify what you're
talking about you're talking about
depreciation
and i think a lot of people were
tweeting about it like and you
and this applies to anything this
applies to like the equipment in this
studio right here yeah right so
i think what happens is they say that
equipment
lasts for five years right so you can
essentially
write off one-fifth of the cost of the
equipment
per year for five years you can actually
write it off in the first year if you
want
but they're basically saying yo the
equipment's getting worse and it's going
to get older and
it actually doesn't hold the same value
that you bought it the appraisal thing
was interesting to me also because i
never heard that before
so with the building for example if you
have a building and you bought it for
100 million and then next year they're
like yeah but look the bathrooms are all
old and all it says was worn down
it's worth 90 million that 10 million
you get to write off that loss
if you will in the in the value of the
asset
so what's really interesting is you
write off the loss
but then you put 10 million dollars in
to make up for that loss of your own
money and you get to write off
the investment that you're putting in
now you're writing off 20 million
exactly so basically what they do
and you're probably raising the rent
because you improve the building and
you're gonna tell your tenants
hey look what we did to the building
more rent so you're just making money
both ways the name of the game i guess
is how do i prove that everything i have
is losing as much money as i'm making
and then you
come out to zero and as long as you're
at zero you maintain all the wealth
that's within the asset
you're describing the business model of
amazon this is amazon right they don't
pay any taxes
you know why break it down because so
look this is a court this is how
corporations do it not just people
that's why we gotta have a whole
conversation
amazon has this thing called amazon web
services most people don't even know
this they think amazon's retail company
no it's server company vast majority of
its income so what it does
is it takes this money printing machine
amazon web services
and then invests it and covers losses
that's how they're able to sell you you
know you go on amazon you see like
amazon basics products and it's always
cheaper than whatever the competitor is
yeah that's not because they know how to
make it cheaper or they
send it cheaper they can just take the
loss because it's being subsidized by
another part of the company
right and that way they never
technically have profit
because they're always investing their
money
into other areas but what does that mean
that means that they can
kill all of their competitors so they
never pay any taxes
but somehow jeff bezos is worth what
[ __ ] 200 million 200 billion dollars
how does that happen this is what we
have to understand so
it's all a scam i went on uh i did a
tour once of europe
right and uh i didn't look at the
contracts as well as i should have
because i never like reading any of the
[ __ ] i just looked at the number at the
bottom and i was like oh this is what
i'm gonna make i'll be good right
and this is actually the tour where uh
alex got arrested alex is our video
producer over here
and so it ended up being very costly
well done alex
and uh don't go to uh sweden sauger okay
they're rough on the browns
okay i don't know if we would we would
last there huh i don't think so no no no
i don't think
so so uh uh
what class are you again cast are you
rajput
yeah yeah would you sell him down the
river dude would you be like
take
so i'm there and um at the end of the
tour i'm looking at the money that i
made and i had like some shows like in
london that like really sold out and
then we did some shows in like sweden
they didn't sell that made tickets
and the shows in london we just kept
adding shows and it was crazy
and i looked at what we made in sweden
and i was like all right we didn't make
that much money but like
that's on the promoter of the gig i
guess he lost money on that gig you know
it is what it is
and um then i looked at the overall
contract and i realized that the gigs
were cross-collateralized
which means which is what amazon does
essentially to protect themselves right
so
they were like hey if we don't meet a
certain amount of money in sweden
we're going to take it from the london
shows
right and that's what these companies
are doing to allow themselves to grow is
they don't even have to profit as long
as they have one thing that's making
money
they just write off those losses like
what a lot of i think sports team owners
do
too yeah that's like the sports nfl same
way nfl
they might lose money or the team might
lose money but they have a real estate
business or they have some other
business a restaurant business
and they'll write off the losses in
their sports team
versus the gains that they make in
whatever
and that's why i don't believe when nba
owners are like we lose 200 million a
year
supporting the team it's like i know you
show that you lost 200 million
to pay less taxes i don't think he
actually lost 200 million
but you never believe it my question to
you sagar is what would be your tax
solution because it feels like any
wealth tax you create
they're going to find a way out of it
and then everybody else is going to pick
up the bill
great question too man which is i'm not
necessarily in favor of wealth tax like
whenever people say
wealth tax like i think what they're
saying is billionaires should pay more
taxes
from i've done a lot of research into
this basically as far as you can see
a wealth tax would probably is i
wouldn't say it's unfair but it would
just discourage
i mean look like maybe this is my
conservative part of me but like we
still have a lot of [ __ ] billionaires
for a reason right like people do create
awesome companies here in the united
states like you don't necessarily want
to discourage that what you want and
what i want is balance like i think it's
crazy
for the top 50 to own nothing especially
people who are younger you know
like probably listening to this podcast
or like 30 years old have literally no
chance
at accumulating any wealth whatsoever so
i actually think it comes mostly from
the financial industry
everything you need every dollar you
need is sitting right on wall street
in hedge fund transactions and so many
of the different things that these guys
get away with
1 000 x profit all of that it's not a
mystery like it's it's sitting
right there like these guys are able to
make record-setting profits every single
year
by depreciating their stuff and moving
around their assets
and the amount of money that is
interchanging you can tax financial
transactions you could raise a billion
here's another one we're talking about
taxes there there's a
this is a study that came out actually
in the national bureau of economic
research
just in case anybody wants to start
checking me and it says that
you could raise 1 trillion a trillion in
revenue
with a 1 7 size investment on irs
just tax enforcement so that's not even
a new tax that's just enforcing
enforcing tax laws that we have on the
books
right now so there you go like a
trillion dollars that's a lot of money
that's more than the entire military
budget
so this this is the easier things i'm
trying to think about sagar those all
sound great but how much will we make if
we just
bought greenland
i mean greenland is priceless man i i
can't even you can't even put a number
on it right
i think i think that's the solution to
be honest with you look i love greenland
so we should buy it
dude i appreciate your time man thank
you so much for clearing this up you
sound like an undercover bernie bro i
just want to say i know that you please
no
you always tell me that it's not true
it's not true my position's on
immigration and everything then they get
mad
oh really
tell me tell me tell me tell me what is
the uh oh god dude you're going to make
me
we don't have to go down we can that's
fine what i mean i want to know
i want to know do you do you wish that
you're a great friend it's an old school
bernie position so they really shouldn't
be mad at me
okay okay you know you go back and you
look at what bernie sanders saying 2015
and what you're saying in 2020 he was
like open borders is a koch brothers
proposal
or something and then all of a sudden
you know the democratic party and the
elite media shifts one way and now
bernie's all for open borders
so some people are mad that i said that
he's effectively for
open borders even though the guy used to
understand
um that that depresses a lot of
americans wages
okay now uh last question this is very
important to a lot of our listeners so
answer carefully okay
cashmere you know what it is y'all
you only have to think twice about this
saga you know what the [ __ ] it is yo
you're right i already know what it is
you know what it is
what is it what is it now soccer
pakistan or india bro
look i my position can be summed up in
two words
[Applause]
i say that as both as an american
citizen and as a person of indian
descent
hey man i only care about that second
one yo
that's what's up stay true oh god yo
sagar we love you man tell them where
they can find you one more time
that's right uh it's real alignment
podcasts or on rising over at the hill
on youtube esauger on twitter uh and
instagram thank you guys for having me
and congrats on the patreon thing
hey appreciate it and for real i'm
telling you sorry you do these great
what do you call them
monologues okay so he does these but you
you call them your it's called
my radar my room yeah his radar so and
you do it daily
and uh and it's great it's a deep dive
onto a single subject and he was really
nuanced and really researched and um
i get a lot of information from them and
i think you guys should check it out
literally it's one of those things
where even today i went for it before i
texted you on youtube
to see if you did it on the trump tax
thing today
are you there now you're welcome i'm
glad dude i'm glad
i'm glad that you guys can talk about it
no no it's important yeah yeah no but
i'm what i'm saying is i'll often look
to you as a resource for information so
let me see if you cut out there so it's
all good let me see if sagar
did a radar on this thing and i'll get
some information so make sure you go
check it out we'll throw a link in the
in the description but thank you so much
man i appreciate you brother jahan
thanks guys see you later peace